c'est maintenant une coutume voilà que
jean marie bigard a posté samedi dernier
un nouveau coup de gueule sur sa page
facebook comme à son habitude filmées de
très près l'humoriste est une nouvelle
fois montré sa colère contre le
gouvernement et ses mesures autour du
confinement il s'est d'abord agacé du
discours du gouvernement autour des
masques que certains responsables
politiques avaient d'abord désigné comme
inutile pour le grand public c'est fort
c'est un mensonge c'est pas que c'est
pas utile c'est qu'on les a pas avant de
s'adresser directement au président de
la république est président peux tu
changes ton équipe tu as juste à
traverser la rue c'est comme vont
trouver du boulot tu prends n'importe
quel tocard qu'elle sur le trottoir d'en
face
il sera mieux que ces trois guignols
s'attaque ensuite un sujet qui lui tient
particulièrement à coeur la réouverture
des bars ont ré ouvre donc à partir de
lundi les métros les trains les avions
qui auront bientôt 70 % de remplissage
nous dit on beaucoup on rouvre pas les
bars pour l'humoriste
il n'y a aucune raison valable c'est à
dire un mec un peu quand même discuter
le bout de gras prouve
[ __ ] il ya deux cent mille entreprises
entre les les bistrots les brasseries
qui sont en train de crever rouvre du
papa et poserait un ricard avec
modération ou un double oui car même si
jamais l envie mais récupérer un peu de
joie à l'heure actuelle
emmanuel macron ne semble pas avoir
répondu à son appel affaire à suivre
alors vous êtes pour ou contre la
réouverture des bars allez c'est parti
qui est d'accord avec jean marie bigard
qui n'est pas d'accord vous vous êtes
d'accord moi je suis d'accord ce que
franchement de ce que j'ai vu ce matin
en tout cas des premiers jours de
confinement les gens c'est vrai ils ont
ils avaient une vraie envie de sortir
ils se réunissent il ya peu d'espoir des
espaces se créent dans des magasins dans
des supermarchés dans l'est dans les
boutiques etc
mais dans la rue franchement il n'ya pas
un mètre de sécurité des gens sont assez
proches quand même et dans un bar
on aurait pu quand même donner une
bouffée d'oxygène à eau à ce commerce là
qui vendant qu'il pâtit vraiment très
durement depuis depuis plus de deux mois
et gailland plus on arrive dans la
période où il fonde plus de she parce
qu'il ya des terrasses et sert à même d
ouvrir les terrasses sont - enfin il y
avait moyen de trouver des systèmes qui
accommodent quand même un peu tout le
monde joue et je trouve que ça me fait
du bien le déconfinement au fait des
phrases longues 150 sans abri non mais
c'est vrai en 4g mais franchement en 4g
vous avez été en tête pendant des
semaines et des semaines week end non
moi je pense que c'est propre à chacun
de savoir de se dire si la raison ou pas
mais ce que je sais c'est que jean marie
bigard il ya énormément de français mais
vraiment énormément qui sont d'accord
avec lui oui après cd façon de dire les
choses que chacun ne dirais pas de la
même manière mais quand vous voyez je
chevaux chacun voit midi à sa porte
oui bien sûr chacun voit midi à sa porte
quand vous voyez les transports l'état
des transports actuels aujourd'hui les
vidéos qu'on a vu c'est hyper grave
alors l'union nationale on assez vite
alma des vidéos madame cuvée novelli
quand vous étiez au gouvernement vous
faisiez pas mieux on a des vidéos on
verra ça tout à lui vous allez me dire
c'est vital c'est pour les gens et pour
l'économie etc ah oui mais l'économie
c'est aussi les bars les restaurants et
quand tu vas dans un magasin de
prêt-à-porter et qu' il ya les filles
qui touche à tous les vêtements et kif
qui mais qu'ils essayent les vêtements
et yahia pas mesures de sécurité je suis
dit que ouvrir des terrasses pour lé
barça peut être quand même sympa voilà
merci c'est un bon résumé alors raymond
bien sûr que les livreurs en plus
vaudois sont oui puisqu'ils livre je
suis moi je suis touché en plein dedans
comme à dijon matois été touché en plein
coeur lancé mais oui j'ai touché un peu
cherché en plein dans ses 250 millions
250 mille entreprises c9000 en 1900
milles emplois
neuf cent mille emplois c'est beaucoup
dans le golfe baptiste au maire de
papeete envie d'être avec lui tu as
envie d'être avec jean-marie et dire oui
ouvrez les barthes en vie sauf que c'est
différent d'un magasin de fringues ou tu
vas prendre tes affaires avec des gants
et pointue mais pas des aliments dans ta
bouche là c'est directement un cuistot
tu vas peut-être tous ses danseurs dans
ton platiau pia pia pas
la stabilité on n'est pas pressé pressé
on n'est pas dix jours quinze jours près
laissons le temps d'avancé et après on
va rouvrir les bars je pense moi je vais
s'ils étaient joints je cite et didier
barbelivien il faut laisser le temps au
temps
mais si je peux me permettre il ya un
moment donné il ya vraiment rentrés soit
en découd fine soit on découvre une part
mais ça n'a rien à voir
manon boily un mode en ligne financé
progressif voilà on déconfinement trop
grossi et donc vous confesser plus
important du verre des magasins cas par
cas où on n'a pas dès lors qu'on était
contre l'ouverture des bars on donne
notre avenir on dit voilà s'il ya des
mesures de sécurité moi je sais on va
demander des nations mais voilà si les
gens se reste à distance exactement et
il a visiblement ça va être
établissement par établissement au cas
par cas effectivement j'entends et moi
je suis comme raymond j'ai envie de dire
oui bah ouvre bien déroulée
non mais voilà moi j'ai envie moi j'ai
envie mais on reste confiné c'est ça le
problème et non merci ont décompté moi
j'ai presque envie de vous dire allez
faire un tour dans le jardin non mais
voilà effectivement il faut que la vie
reprenne mais que la vie reprenne et que
ça fasse trop con qu'on commence par les
choses entre guillemets qui font sens
ils sont vite à l'aise pour les uns et
les autres et puis petit à petit on va
aller l'oiseau fait de l'agrément est
donc en l'occurrence les brisent les
bistrots les restaurants même si pour
certains c'est vital c'est aussi de
l'agrément moi je pense que les fringues
gens qui sont garants d'un restaurant le
match fédérer s'il vous plaît madame
mais les meneurs plus encore que le
restaurant parce que c'est vrai que moi
être au zinc jean raibaut si il ya un
exemple qu'il soit là on peut acheter un
vêtement avec un 3 5
oui au barça à l'aller vous là les mecs
là c'est jean gabin 80 à nîmes et
clermont newey alors l on peut acheter
vêtements avec un masque on peut pas
consommer avec un masque en plus bien
sûr transmission est plus grand et le
danger est plus grand
mais moi aussi j'en rêve de la
rouverture que vous allez c'est
paradoxal on regarde la ligne 13 est
hyper bondée du midi pas qu'une ligne 13
comme ça il a bandé et moins dangereuse
et bien bas resteront qu'on peut
aménager avec des connaisseurs sécurité
optimale on peut semer trop tu peux pas
t'en pc alors que le mas hélas tu peux
t'en passer avec en théorie d'un
original t'es dans la merde
non c'est les bières qui est dramatique
obligé de jeter toute la production
c'est ce qu'ils peuvent pas les compte
même pas avec la corona et en a pas une
qui se bourrent qui se bougent comme ça
c'est pas une basse et 90 pour son choix
le sud oui la chute des deux courses et
associés au virus et le met des gens
ouf le mec tu commences à lui est tombé
sur le coin de la gueule et le virus
s'il s'était appelé fanta ça cool non
mais c'est vrai ah oui bon voilà même
rigolé mais c'est pas con c'est ce que
je dis c'est pas con ce que je dis les
sirops voir ce qu'en pensent les
téléspectateurs tient on à un sondage
pour à 62% contre à 38% voilà les
shérifs